the Wildfire disaster in Northern
California is worsening and there
appears to be no end in sight the fires
are now blamed for at least 23 deaths
285 other people are reported missing
though officials suspect many of them
are just out of touch with loved ones
3500 homes and businesses have been
destroyed think about this there are
entire towns that are under evacuation
orders Highway Patrol officers went
door-to-door in parts of Sonoma County
overnight strongly advising homeowners
to leave get out at least 22 large fires
are burning in California at this hour
Carter Evans is in Santa Rosa where
firefighters are still having trouble
getting into some burned out areas
Carter good morning good morning I'm
standing in front of what was once a
Kmart that has been obliterated you can
just imagine how hot it was to bend
those steel i-beams and take a look
inside you could see the burned out
shopping carts there this is what it
looked like when it was fully engulfed
firefighters say there was nothing they
could do towering flames lit up the
night sky a warning to those still in
the path of the wildfire in parts of
California the safest place to view it
is from the Air California Highway
Patrol captured hillsides and towns
burning to the ground there's been fires
that just blow through this has been
going on for three days with no
resolution we're just on the edge right
now the fires had now burned about 265
square miles an area half the size of
Los Angeles we are in this fight for the
long haul it's going to continue to get
worse before it gets better
more than 8,000 firefighters are facing
extremely dry conditions gusty winds
some topping 75 miles per hour are
changing direction with each passing
minute any change in these winds and
it's pushing the the fire right through
the sky grass towards homes
battalion chief Jonathan Cox says some
of these firefighters have been working
nonstop since Sunday they're fighting
extreme exhaustion with some men
catching sleep whenever they can we have
dozens of firefighters who've been
affected themselves lost homes had
families who've been impacted and
there's the ladder fire still out here
fighting the fire new video from when
the Wildfire broke out show's first
responders driving right into the
inferno more than 20,000 people have
been evacuated from their homes one
family puts sprinklers on their roof and
begged first responders to save their
house meanwhile some are returning to
the most devastated areas for the first
time to see the damage up close this is
absolutely devastating it's it's
heartbreaking it is crushing this looks
like another planet 98% of all wildfires
are caused by people but it is still not
clear what caused this one there were
reports of very windy weather downing
trees power poles and power lines before
the fire began on Sunday Pacific Gas and
Electric The Electric Company out here
says it notified fire officials right
away and they are now investigating
Charlie thanks Carter